did you take these DDT
[Music]
then shove it into light then over if he
starts to reach you can use your legs to
boom he starts to reach
[Music]
port ends after throws you don't get you
have a fall and then so very much like
that about the song we were using where
I have to stay connected ticket right or
the folder rolls where you use the
momentum transfer it's the same thing so
he goes right into it you see that and
we end up in this position so your
finish line is not here a new race
that's not your finish line is all the
way over into it into the pin so we go
slow but I'm going to smooth see I'm
still moving with it so then there's no
hardware he stops having then we'll
mention transfer through
so I'll give you some variation when I
come around here right I can take it
this way so I was I did the throw and
I'm gonna bend the arm with my body you
see that you guys see that kind of young
kill and then you never want to walk
around them you want to keep her moving
so when I bid Mauro I just shove that
down and then she's in the leg drop and
then that's the walk is right there okay
so that's it that's a good one to look
for right is to get this bend to go here
because then you just press down so she
moves out of the way when they're armed
boom you saw the strike they just
presses down then you move into position
or if she's extending her energy she's
not pulling into you just push pushing
your way you see that yo you're gonna
find that pin part so you just push it
over into her face and you end up in the
same exactly
so as as you can't you don't want to
pull your arm back you want to man up
and get a arm stretch and then cuz
they're not gonna just get your harm and
doesn't give it back
do you see you you're not gonna get it
back alright so this case I'm too far
right to get it she pulls her arm but
you see the gooey center here okay so
she can push up with that hand so you
pull that arm up okay so now that was
Jeff both arms then then you have a pin
again okay boom boom and ain't quite
dinner right so I checked this one she
goes to push up and that's when you
catch this on bring it back behind and
then this one's a little different I'll
bring this up towards our head so last
time I would still be here right catch
you TR Center this time to you a slot so
I I come up towards your head okay then
I come back here get on your knees you
see you go back down get on your knees
okay so you'll feel where that tightness
is so you're not gonna counter you can
blend with me that's it no here's your
counter Thanks
issue putter Nisa and I would tap up
which white count hey DJ along on the
first pan okay so this part so when I
when I come around here
I'm already coming on the other side of
this bun you see that it's not over here
straight it's gonna be over here okay so
that I'm not pushing this shoulder down
I'm pushing in his whole back down so do
you see that difference okay so you
can't have the hand over here you got to
get it across his body
and you're aiming for that whole box
what's the actual link here not wait
here because he'll pivot around that
okay so we'll do it slow on the other
side and who can you know face for job
so again boom right to his face is where
that's going and already I'm thinking to
get this across his body you see that so
I'm gonna be here
don't take it here you'll bend his elbow
take it across this bar okay okay okay
so now the pin part okay so this part is
over here okay so when she comes to baby
reach for me let's do the reach for my
leg you see that so she comes back she
goes to reach I come up up from the
shoulder where she can't reach me we see
how to do that okay and then look that's
where my weight good so I don't want to
put too much on her but you can see as
I'm trying to get this other pin my
weights going down on there right
Virginie so that's the best idea
okay so we'd like to be nice and I could
do it over here
but the idea is to shift your weight
onto that arm okay I'm doing all this I
get this pin you see that and like all
he has to do is shift there you go you
think to come back even if I make it
really tight ship yes
so yeah it's gonna be tight right so
we've just flipped over I have it when
he goes down you got to get that hand
off the mat okay you're looking for and
then just come up with you so look how I
can use my body so you use my body then
I can get my weapon out so when you
swing you go to throw this is where
you're connected you're looking for that
hand and come around to come up oh there
it is capture it get it underneath your
abdomen and all your weights on it all
right and you can draw your
and you end up on this side like that
okay so she comes to get that arm goes
to change the angle right would I don't
have a very good angle you see that and
so what I'm going to do instead is
immediately drop to this one then
capture this arm okay writer things boom
right and I know oh I can't get that one
right so I drop into this one and she
goes to push up and I capture the arm
and I bring it across and then I can
free my hands again okay boy under feet
boom drop she goes boom pick it up bring
it in front and now your hands are free
then check for her weapons or whatever
sometimes you have to move on so right
when I go to here right right
my movement is forward so we'll just uh
you'll tap out when you don't like it
okay open it the idea is this boom boom
here so on the last one you're more on
the arm and this way you're more on the
shoulder blade you see that you feel
that and I keep down and I would just
keep walking okay so it would look like
I'm here and I use all my weight goes on
her boom and I walk off with it okay so
so really slow move right onto her
shoulder blade I go she pulls her arm
away I'll forget it man I snap guard as
they walk yeah